so ever since our [__] press
conference finished I've been getting
tweets instagrams the law every [__]
minute probably what were you thinking
during that press conference well I
haven't watched this press conference
back since it happened because three
honestly I didn't enjoy doing it it was
the one of the few YouTube events I felt
really frustrated gern and like Fergana
says you didn't have control yeah no
[__]
a Norwood your [__] Rogen me like
anyone who is in this situation with a
crowd like that was people who own
professional fighters who on try not
make fresh players and I'm trying to ask
questions it's like trying to rob a bank
when someone's already set the alarm off
Lynn you haven't got a [__] brain so
I just did me best but I didn't feel
like it came out the way I wanted it to
that being said there were some [__]
entertaining moments I'm gonna [__]
watch it and I'm gonna shoot from there
be brutally honest here I just want to
say straight off the bat you have no
idea how loud they were like I've been
in Wembley when there's been like thirty
forty thousand people you're in a
massive open space or the sound just
travels up basically and like you're so
enclosed it makes it feel a trillion
times louder than Wembley Stadium like
everyone who walk on that stage would
have felt something because those
[__] in that crowd were so loud
so before Jay comes out I'd walk past
Jake and Logan backstage and I know as
an interview are the best thing you can
do to get good answers is to get people
warmed up to you but I have 0% chance of
that because Logan knows everything a
[__] setup up in the bus and be quite
honest I do think what he did was
[__] terrible but at the same time
I'm trying to do a [__] job here it's
almost like WWE whatever we think about
each other let's put that aside for the
next half an hour I've got work with
these lads and try and get answers out
with them as best I can and I just
looked at them dead in the eye said
let's have a good show
that's it you know what I'm saying walks
on stage announcers Jake Paul coming to
the stage it's chase Paul
hey boo instead she's a [__] that's
crazy I thought you guys are a desease
team so I'm stood behind the [__]
podium there look at a jig who is
getting so much abuse like few people in
their lifetime will ever have that many
people screaming at them like that like
literally you have to go back the one
used to [__] chop people's heads off
you know I mean with people who come out
bring out your dance this is the level
of hatred he's dealing with
and honestly I'm sitting there thinking
you handled it well all of these music
performances he must do
must have [__] sucked I'm in good
stead for this because he just acted
like it was no big deal and Fair Play
it doesn't mean I like his videos but I
respect that
thank y'all for coming out tonight thank
y'all for coming out tonight to the show
he gets it he gets it to show you see
what I'm saying so when I was walking
towards him he was making eye contact
with me and he knew what we he was on my
site to some extent I felt like re I can
work with this kid which in this
situation is [__] helpful you know I
mean I was grateful for that nobody
throwing anything people were throwing a
lot of Cher was doing me [__] headed
Deji walks in smacks the [__]
microphone off of the table I'm like
guess I better pick that up then cuz
neat [__] else is gonna on this stage
I found myself doing a lot of jobs I was
production I was security God I was a
nun so I was [__] wouldn't beat I
don't mind it but like it's stressful
and then you got to try and get a nun
some of these loves well at this point I
was cringing I was just like oh yeah
this isn't good Nicole how I want it is
it it's going the way of the earlier
what I thought I've got very little
chance of getting anything at this point
in dead she's just not listening to the
word I'm saying people are throwing
stuff it was I'd gone from making a
documentary about Kanye West to they say
I was just thinking like what am i doing
well [__] Jay Paul for cheap or watching
well I was really panicking inside know
because they'd just been non-stop like
chanting and I
the problem is is the only press
conference most people have seen is the
McGregor mayweather ones which were
nothing like a proper fight Prescott
on account of tree I want everyone in
this arena to scream at the top of your
lungs
[__] them Mayweather's so now everyone
things like you just gotta like go up
there and shunt like a [__]
cheerleader or something you know I'm
trying to ask questions now a dead she's
just screaming boys I'm like what have I
done
yeah a lot of people are saying that you
were talking chair chair to get the dead
she fight cuz it's an easier fight it's
not true literally he couldn't hear a
[__] thing I was so [__] loud so
loud he stopped throwing [__] cuz
everyone's gonna go home
alright alright chick me and Jake watch
you having a laugh yeah it was weird
like I actually thought the kids seemed
alright we fail that G dad she's just
laughing hysterically I love like [__]
you guys just be a dick just keep this
going it was I'm looking back at it now
and it wasn't as bad as it felt like up
there I felt like I was dying I just I
just felt like I was dying on stage did
you know and you're a comedian and
you've got no jokes and that was
basically what it felt like partner oh
that really struck a chord by the way
when he said about his training partners
I looked across daddy's trading partners
look like they wanted a rift chase
[__] head off bit dull and ksi are
actually training they trained for the
Weller fight they know what to think
about Jake as he does his homework I've
noise like he pays very close attention
to is bizarre with him when he started
rattling off things about the sidemen I
was like oh you you are paying attention
to [__] yeah he's not just going in
blind
I have to admit right
Angie said home of zero what the
champions like it's just quite amusing
because he's obviously thought about
this ship before Arnold to fix boxing
gym
we trained edgy and that's it genuinely
right I'll [__] hate myself right now
because I do a lot of people be like are
you supporting Jake I'm not a [__]
team deggi right he's obviously like me
me not saying I'm best mates the by any
[__] means bought Jake dealt with the
hate the [__] so [__] well on
that I was I was impressed with that
anyway he's still just like [__] do you
think he's deliberately just like [__]
God Almighty I think this is where I get
annoyed so I'm getting hit them directed
a lot I'm quite a calm dude but like
when I start losing it it really goes
quickly Tom do you think that Jake is
deliberately putting bare minimum videos
up to make it look like he's not
training so he's got excuses or Jesus
like he's trying to hide it from you
know I just hoping to fight better than
he can dress I was literally nothing to
do with a question asked like for anyone
just slugged me I'm watching this but
right and it felt like and car crush
when I was there what people don't know
son is how loud the crowd was and having
to keep these two characters cool here
and not just screaming at each other
[__] me I tried me [__] best like I
really [__] I've had so much hatred
from the logger and [__] fans after
obviously I let that gwaan and I'll get
lighten them in a book you know I'm
clearly trying to be [__] fair what's
your opinion so far of all of the
footage you've seen of Deji sporran
[Applause]
condom I'm getting annoyed at that point
the footage of daddy spine he gets hit
in the stomach one girl and he drops to
the ground what do you say I think at
this point I'm like let's rub this tough
football like I just got sick and tired
I thought I got a couple of decent
answers there this is the best I'm gonna
[__] me let's do the [__] face I'm
looking at the paper there and I'm not
even reason I'm looking to try and make
it look like I know what the [__] I was
like what the [__] this is in the blood
the party they did it gloves are off
with Johnny Nelson I was like that's
what I should have done like I know
these youtubers back Johnny Nelson's a
legend but I know these lads like I know
the stories I can read up on me like I
could have done a [__] great gloves
are of misses just like I put in any air
of God laughter you're the bigger guy if
you don't win it's not not even more
humiliating for you since Teddy is
clearly smaller than you you're still
wearing there's zero percent chance for
you there's your purse as I check the
heels oh I did and you know as I
literally thought meself there nice
shoes actually like I quite like the
thing about Jake is he's got [__]
money so he wasn't wearing like tacky
[__] have you faced the lobby and the
suit is questionable but the shoes were
theses I love how beauty by highlighted
me [__] eyes going down checks if
he's actually wearing totally straight
away you can't know check out the shoes
there's 0% chance at that she went to
spite his old trainer knows it his
brother knows it the side man when when
Jake's going off yes a in the side man
fatale kicked them out the house I feel
like he's scoring points cuz he's coming
with with [__] now he's turning those
[__] in there questionable half-truths
like why did they kick them out the
house did that actually happen but
especially since Jake was more hit I
felt like he came out not the winner in
the eyes of the crowd but I feel like
people watching her home would feel like
he saw an edge the press conference here
let's do a faceoff right now
what annoyed me here a little bit this
straightaway as soon as the face-up
comes like every [__] and their dog or
onstage like I can handle this you lot
to stay the [__] away I'm big enough to
make sure that these two lads don't but
the problem is he's the fear the fear
everyone has in him that what if my guy
gets smart or whatever like I don't know
I didn't it was there was gang mentality
and it sort of annoyed me a little bit
no I wanted to [__] them I slapped
that [__] by the end to be honest really
I mean the other point what you saying
but I'm looking at him like how the [__]
do you expect me to control this lot of
[__] crazy bastards in the crowd I'm
not [__] god I can't just be like
Bruce Almighty do you not I mean they're
gonna do what they're gonna do I'm
telling them they're just not [__]
listen to me and if the lot listen to me
I'll give you the [__] mic and see of
you about look I've always quite
interesting that Jeff didn't look at him
first time around he almost like ignored
him completely like I've seen that
tactic used by John Jones actually he
does seem to like get under people's
skin a bit
[Applause]
I knew he was going to turn at that
point I [__] knew he was gonna
because there's no fear in Jake Paul
towards dodgy I don't think there's any
fear from Deji either but he didn't back
down to the challenge I stopped feeling
so many people gathering round and edgy
looks like he's just ready to [__] go
like at this point and obviously it's
not dead she and Jake I'm worried about
it's the [__] another 20 [__] dudes
around one stage because once one
[__] [__] goes that's it the whole
stage is gone and all the [__] press
conference is finished I was so stressed
out at that point I was like I think I'm
ready to go home here they're telling me
at this point get these [__] off
stage which frustrated me a bit I felt
like the production team sort of give me
a mic because they would have all been
get paid but like yeah you wouldn't do
our jobs for us like I felt like I could
have done with a bit of [__] help at
this point like I was just out there on
me [__] or and on stage and having
the Corral every con to get them off the
[__] thing coming to the stage
the Challenger Logan Paul introduced in
Logan to the sage was bizarre
to be honest because like five months
ago he did what he did I mean the video
slate man [__] sick little [__]
freak do you know that you know MD you
are insight you've shown your true
colors to everyone now [__] my most
popular video ever and then Garry is I'm
[__] introduced in this ditch like I
know the world is weird
do you know what I'm saying I've got to
say decent suit there's nothing else the
level of hate he got when he came out
was [__] incredible like because of
what he's done in the past thing I feel
like Jay got here but like Logan's hey
it was just like once-in-a-lifetime like
you basically have to be a [__] PTO's
and serial killers you don't you see
their vans getting transported from like
prison tack or they don't get this kinda
[__] like I'm on stage and even I'm a
bit like taken aback by it like [__] me
it was written all over him that he was
struggling with it you know what I mean
and I don't actually blame him for he
probably deserves it for what he did a
little bit but like I say it
pedo serial killer type level he didn't
actually kill anyone you know what I'm
saying it was a bit extreme but maybe
it'll do him some good
you know I'm an eagle wise at that point
may Logan we don't look each other's
direction there's no eye contact me just
nothing like and just by that you can I
just tell he's seen the [__] video I
made about them and good do you know I
mean I think there was a lot of things
to set my video he should have heard I
was comfortable with her I'm absolutely
fine with that it was the crowd that was
that was weird
children I mean the reigning defending
you to top of the world
this is way
I just want to be in and out some on our
[__] love that type of ship building
someone up and feeling the crowd get
hype when you talk in a nice there's
something about the power of spoken word
like you just can't [__] match it and
someone who dreamt of being like a
sports commentator getting to announce
like a champion even if it is a YouTube
champion to a crowd of people who are
posing as that as you'd say in the words
and that a [__] feels electric like
it feels something special when it's
going good
it feels great when it's going bad it
feels [__] terrible
when JJ comes out make no mistake like
they were there for him every single
person apart from one apart from one
girl it was like towards the front she
was dropping the Logan Mavericks I know
whatever I was like she had the t-shirts
everything she was like [__] Deji [__]
JD like she was like ride or die like if
you could have one fart like that thing
you are safe alive shield my everything
very plato and JJ comes out way in the
blond wig and I'm like [__] how like
no one's taken none of you this time he
owned that entire room at that point and
like I knew he was gonna go in straight
away has already suffered enough
we lost the Croatian in the semi-final
we had truck come over last week now we
got you this week Logan it was just
shook he's looking at me sort of like
what the [__] happening girlfriend now
[Applause]
Chloe Bennet
what's up babes
[Applause]
Norvin sat in his chair slumped like
body language not aggressive not a fight
I just just take and everything not a
word to say by everyone in the room is
chat in his girlfriend's a ho like
there's a public ridicule of Logan Paul
this was not a press conference at this
point and there wasn't a [__] thing I
could do about it you really think
anyone I'm [__] big voice I'm a big
block / ksi is loved by these people in
this room listen they're not listening
to [__] from anyone else the train is
gone dude I mean he's team he's the
train driver and I'm on the platform all
the B parts do you know what I mean and
Logan is in [__] coach just dumb for
the ride and wherever he goes there's
nothing he can do about it
apparently you only have 85% of your
testicle let me give her the extra 50
I'm trying to keep a straight face at
this point but change is just going in
and the thing is people were saying like
oh you should have stopped them
I'll give Jake and edgy both a chance to
open their sort of set their stalls and
see what they want to say before we
answer questions i was expect-- and
Logan just jump in at some point and it
started up from self against who JJ I
wasn't expecting I just get the part and
still not end up in the final movie my
song ended up in the final movie when
where were you oh yeah deleted scenes at
that point I looked at Logan I'm
thinking all right he's laughing it off
but he's gonna come back with something
soon I was wrong Logan's looking at me
repeatedly now he's starting to look at
me like come on like stop this stop this
I'm thinking dude like this is this is
your press conference you press
conferences especially ones this
childish or ones that are just a [__]
talking contest you know I mean and I'm
gonna get there but like do you have to
interrupt them icon in there of JJ I'm
not the [__] opposition you are
you're the opponent everyone has my back
and no one has yours besides your
ludicrous mom
delusional diets so this point we're
saying a whole entourage of log and
pause guys he had some big [__] dudes
with them I'm not even get a lot even I
was like yeah this kicks office is gonna
be a [__] bloodbath yelling cuz
there's a massive [__] one
person it wasn't massive was Logan's dad
who seemed to be the most anxious to get
[__] started like he seemed to want
to fight straight away and you're
looking like dude like you shouldn't
even be here I mean like JJ and Daddy
starts probably sat with his [__]
slippers on to the home was watching TV
like he's not getting a lot this is not
a place for parents yeah and like he
ended up being not like embarrass and
dad but I'm sure I'm sure you wouldn't
mind loss at one run before the little
girls who like kissing that was that was
the stinger that was that was but and
the thing is it was a genius move from
JJ goes straight at the time cuz it's
like he almost makes it even worse
because he's not getting anything from
Logan he's just sat there and he knows
his dad stuffed enough to [__] try
and argue it's just easy pickings for JJ
he just runs rings around I probably
should have tried to step in a bit more
at this point I'll accept that I didn't
realize how long it was but I was like
because I kept motion and JJ like all
right what's lets get shot down but then
when his dad gets up I'm like oh his
dad's gonna go back and forth um now I
guess I've just gotta [__] let this
hop and you know I mean what - dumb ass
children [__] that was really hard not
the best though laughing do so I'm
saying at this point you can't really go
I'm saying right lads that we're gonna
do some questions now is that genuinely
wanted to ask these two some questions
you know I mean I'm like I'd literally
prepared for this like days beforehand
like with questions I wasn't I wasn't
just coming in and making it up like I
really thought about what I wanted to
ask him I had some like pointing
questions but for everyone sitting they
say and all you just let go like and
what about like yeah I'll let it go a
bit too long I'll accept that but like I
wasn't trying to not ask log and a
question deliberately our [__] spend
time think any of these questions [__]
you
when I said I wanted to do some
questions that I think JJ probably could
have done as a favor and suddenly I
understand like he was hell-bent on
winning this this exchange verbally and
destroying Logan mentally he wasn't
trying to help him he was trying to
destroy Logan but Logan wasn't helping
himself oh and he was getting gunned
down at this point and he looks at me
and no one else in the room would have
seen that but it was weird it was like
you know in a movie where something
s'mores down and you say something in
slow motion and it's like the heel up
that is enough I seem like defeat in his
eyes I got and I don't mean that he's
gonna lose the fight I just mean he knew
he was [__] and he's like can we [__]
it can help me out of it yeah like the
things that really annoyed me the most
about the first time I ever seen a local
video was the suicide forest was his
treatment of someone in a vulnerable
position you know it was almost like you
know when it fast-forwards through like
months at a time or whatever and all of
a sudden you're like at the next point
and I'm like I'm looking down on this
guy now
physically literally looking down on him
and he's looking at me for help and I'm
looking at him like almost feeling sorry
for him to be honest we in like and some
people be like Joey my [__] how these
like he's supposed to hate this guy and
I [__] still am disgusted in his
actions but it was almost like he became
human for a minute there was like I'd
built a slide up in my head of a piece
of [__] and then to see him in a in a
real moment of like actually he's just a
lot who got lucky on social media he was
a party quite a bright kid at school or
whatever thought he was funny wanted to
push the limit [__] up and actually is
capable of being bullied like anyone
elses and it was interesting the same on
the receiving end of it in person
because it's one thing to see a lot of
twits hating you it's another thing to
be in a room where one of the best [__]
talkers on YouTube and ksi is [__]
roasting you all his fans are there
pointing and laughing at you calling
your dad a [__] pedo and like I don't
know it was just surreal I did try and
step in like I genuinely did but
at that point it was just too late Logan
was done something happened in Logan's
brain which told him like a last thing I
want now is questions cuz if I was
prying and poking and challenging him
and not in the same way as JJ would but
he doesn't know that I don't think he
could handle any more he was he was done
at that point he looks me in the eyes oh
I'll give him one thing he really showed
us the respect of that which means that
the video I made about him had some form
of impact on him in some way it just
makes you think about things differently
when you read into people more you know
what I mean because you've solved and
I'm not one for putting hate videos out
there but I've been affected by suicide
before and I took real issue what he did
I know you respect what I said in that
video whether he admits it or not on the
video I don't give a [__] I can tell by
the way you look at us I know in some
respects us I just wish I'd gotten the
chance to do a real interview
there's things I wanted to ask for the
Battlement of YouTube you know I wanted
it I wanted to gave Logan a chance to
address some things and not be a [__] do
you know what I mean and out it's just
disappointing because I want to put my
name the things I'm proud of and that
was painful at the end like to be honest
fear final thoughts after the press
conference I think Logan is used to be
in the Alpha he's clearly he was a
bright kid in school from everything
I've learned about him when I was doing
research further questions he's
obviously an amateur wrestler so he was
used to the grind he's a very hard
worker there's things about him that
could make him good in a boxing ring but
we've got no idea if he's got the hand
eye coordination it'd be good one thing
we do know is despite having all that
and going against ksi ksi wasn't enough
we in school dropped out of a college
and I you know he was he had issues but
he made his name play in FIFA and in
theory and when you say that and you'd
look at the size advantage
Logan should be in theory the battle
boxer ball there's something special
about JJ and in a mental battle for
whatever reason he just seems to have
the edge
he's controlled the thing I like about
JJ's personality is in chaos in in a
[__] storm he is calm and I've
watched him sparring and videos that
haven't come out yet way he's taken on a
big [__] dude and he just went as a
storm and lands the killer floor and
knocks this kid clean oh and I feel like
in the previous two press conferences
Logan lost his cool he was the one who
put his hands on JJ first he was the one
who walked now and in this boxing match
keeping your cool is gonna be absolutely
[__] necessary to win and that's why I
think JJ's got the edge right now I feel
like Logan has come up against someone
who can just do everything Logan can do
but better if Logan wants to win this
fight he's gonna have to take JJ out of
his comfort zone and I don't know how
he's gonna do that but he has the size
advantage it's gonna be a really
interesting fight for me this I'm really
really interested obviously I think JJ
is gonna win but it's gonna be
interesting because also JJ has that
size issue to deal with it Logan
the younger in Logan and the emotion and
Logan is something he's going to
struggle to control in this fight
because once again you're gonna have a
[__] crowd screaming at you JJ in
your face connecting you know it's gonna
be so interesting that's all I've got to
say for now obviously I'm gonna stay a
cover in this fight and hopefully do the
commentary so if you want more on the
case I versus Logan Paulette then stay
subscribed to the true
Jordi YouTube channel thanks for
watching and I'll say as later